por cuarta vez las calles de Francia se
llenaron de opositores a la reforma
pensional cientos de miles de personas
se manifestaron en contra del proyecto
impulsado por el gobierno de Manuel
macron que pretende aumentar la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años y que
actualmente está siendo debatida en la
asamblea nacional convocados por los
sindicatos los franceses mantuvieron la
presión
esta reforma no debe pasar y Manuel
macron lo sabe muy bien pero se olvida
es como si todos votaron por su programa
pero no la mayoría de la gente no votó y
los que lo hicieron votaron contra Marín
lepén y no para su programa no debe
olvidar que la democracia se trata de
gobernar para la gente ahora la gente le
está diciendo no
junto a sindicalistas y trabajadores
también estuvieron líderes de izquierda
la fuerza que bloquea el proyecto en la
asamblea creo que el señor mccoon si
está contando con el desgaste está en el
país equivocado no me sorprendería pero
aquí está en Francia y la gente en
Francia tiene un temperamento Rebelde
mucho más que en otros lugares
lo que está pasando con este gobierno es
semana tras semana mes tras mes quitar
derechos a los trabajadores hace unos
meses era el seguro de desempleo Ahora
son las pensiones mañana qué será
desde principios de año los franceses se
han movilizado en todo el territorio Y
si tienen sus exigencias continuarán las
protestas hay una huelga programada para
el próximo 16 de febrero mientras
advirtieron con paralizar el país desde
el 7 de marzo si la situación continúa